mais d'abord donc le cri d'alarmé et de
colère des femmes et des hommes qui
rendent la justice en france samia de
chiens
[Musique]
c'est un véritable cri d'alarmé celui
d'un monde de la justice à bout de
souffle celui des magistrats qui croule
sous les dossiers en attente venu
spécialement de bourges cette vice
présidente de tribunal affirme que
certains de ses collègues ont parfois
moins de 15 minutes à consacrer à chaque
affaire douze minutes ça veut dire 12
minutes pour résumer ce qu'il ya dans le
dossier au parti écoutez le ministère
public qui va requérir ensuite écouté le
prévenu ou son avocat qui va présenter
sa défense et après jugé prendre une
décision concernant ce dossier là tout
ça en 12 minutes pris dans une cadence
infernale les magistrats sont venus
exprimer une perte de sens et une
souffrance au travail travailler vite et
mal ou bien et dans des délais un non
raisonnable c'est compliqué de se
résoudre je trouve à à ce choix là en
réalité même si on y est on y est
confronté donc on essaye de faire au
mieux et c'est ça qui alimente aussi le
sentiment le sentiment d'épuisement des
jeunes parce qu'on commence les
audiences à 9 heures que parfois elles
finissent à 19h 20h 21h s'il le faut un
et qu'on enchaîne qu'on enchaîne qu'on
enchaîne des juges qui enchaînent et des
justiciables qui eux étant bien trop
longtemps que la justice se penche enfin
sur le requin lorsque l'on attend un an
18 mois pour passer devant le juge aux
affaires familiales quand une
association compliqué lorsqu'on attend
trois ans en cour d'appel pour un
licenciement lorsqu'on attend 18 mois
pour voir son agresseur jugé devant un
tribunal correctionnel au delà de la
souffrance au travail des magistrats
derrière ça il ya des gens qui souffrent
parce que la justice n'est pas bien
rendu là un sentiment partagé par toute
l'institution judiciaire greffiers
avocats auxiliaires de justice tous sont
venus dénoncer le même mal être on doit
travailler vite toujours plus vite et
et le risque c'est de bâcler de faire
des erreurs et ça a un impact sur la vie
les justiciables c'est des audiences
interminable parfois jusqu'à 2 3 à 4
heures du matin et on ne peut plus jugé
dans ces conditions les magistrats ne
peuvent plus jouer dans ces conditions
nous avocats nous ne pouvons plus
plaider dans ces conditions au pied du
ministère des finances ils sont venus
réclamer des moyens humains et
financiers des engagements à long terme
au-delà des 600 millions d'euros annoncé
en 2022 ce qu'on déplore dans le cadre
de l'augmentation des budgets de la
justice et qui a une énorme partie de ce
budget qui est affecté à la
pénitentiaire est notamment dans le
cadre des projets de création de prison
donc ça c'est de l'argent qui n'arrive
pas en juridiction nous ce qu'on
voudrait c'est un engagement sur
plusieurs années de recrutement intensif
par exemple un engagement sur dix ans
parce que tous les ans finalement on
regarde combien de magistrats vont être
recruté c'est toujours un peu la
surprise est généralement une mauvaise
surprise pour la première fois de son
histoire l'union syndicale de la
magistrature
majoritaire dans la profession elle
plaît aujourd'hui à la grève dans tous
les tribunaux de france et on va
débattre autour de cette grande misère
de la justice française essayé
d'esquisser aussi des solutions grâce à
mes invités cécile bablin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes vice présidente de
l'union syndicale des magistrats on
viens de l'entendre syndicat majoritaire
aujourd'hui en france françois noël
buffet bonsoir sénateurs l ère du rhône
président de la commission des lois
membre de la commission indépendante
chargée de remettre c'est au mois de
février prochain la synthèse des
doléances remarques et propositions qui
seront remontées des états généraux de
la justice maître basile ader bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes ancien vice
bâtonnier du barreau de paris avocat
associé au cabinet august debouzy avec
nous en duplex florent va dit ok
professeur à sciences po directeur
conseil éthique et souveraineté chez
sopra et steria est une société de
conseil en transformation numérique et
vous avez été conseiller auprès du
ministre de la justice c'était il ya
cinq ans j'accueille également laetitia
culpa éditorialiste politique en soi
laetitia cécile même là je commence
est-ce que c'est vraiment hors norme
hors norme historique pour vous cette
cette mobilisation du jour alors je
pense qu'effectivement on peut dire que
c'est historique parce qu'il ya il ya
unanimité du monde judiciaire qui a
dressé le même les mêmes constats en
réalité nous avons eu le soutien des
quatre conférences président procureur
premier président procureurs généraux
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
cour de cassation je crois que ça n'est
jamais arrivé auparavant simplement nous
nous avons ces constats nous les avions
déjà dénoncé depuis de très nombreuses
années dick est dommage c'est qu'il
n'ait pas été entendu avant et donc je
crois qu'effectivement le ras-le-bol
exprimé la colère elle est là c'est
qu'en réalité cela fait des années que
ces constats la sont sur la table et que
même s'il y a une augmentation du budget
ça n'est pas suffisant parce qu'on part
de trop bas depuis trop longtemps oui on
y reviendra sur ces chiffres
l'augmentation du budget évidemment
françois noël buffet c'est lors de ces
états généraux de la justice vous avez
ressenti l'urgence est justement la
situation historiquement critique à la
vérité cette situation on l'a ressenti
depuis longtemps au sénat la commission
des lois travaille depuis très longtemps
sur le sujet le texte de 2018 ce dernier
a explosé à l'époque par madame
belloubet avait fait l'objet de
discussions intenses au sénat avec les
magistrats avec les avocats avec les
greffiers avec la pénitentiaire et on
sentait très très fortement une attente
très forte en terme de moyens en terme
de stratégie de moyen et long terme
également et en termes de reconnaissance
je crois qu'on l'a pas dit il n'a pas
été évoquée encore mais on sent bien que
dans le monde de la magistrature il ya
aussi un besoin de reconnaissance dans
la fonction et dans le rôle des
magistrats donc ça n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui oui et d'ailleurs ça point
interne où on y reviendra la
responsabilité d' équipe gouvernementale
précédente depuis des décennies bien sûr
évidemment mais nous avions déjà fait
observer à l'occasion de ce texte
notamment sur la partie programmation
budgétaire qu'elle était insuffisante
nous avions travaillé dans un rapport
évoquait réalisé en 2010 est un rapport
sur lequel on évoquait la nécessité
d'accroître de façon substantielle les
moyens de la justice en tous les cas son
budget 1 sur plusieurs années on avait
travaillé pour cinq sur cinq ans
le gouvernement avait déjà à l'époque
réduit la voilure la question est une
question d'argent c'est incontestable
mais ce n'est pas seulement une question
d'argent une question de stratégie
puisque je rappelle que le budget est
affecté par mission et donc il y à la
pénitentiaire qui prend c'est vrai la
majorité du budget mais sur la partie
justice judiciaire classique
organisation du cices pénale ordination
de justice civile on en parle trop peu
ces deux millions deux millions 8,2
millions 800 mille décisions en matière
civile en 2019 pour 380 mille en matière
pénale le civil et heures en très très
grande difficulté dont il a besoin dans
une réponse de fond alors lire de
stratégie on y reviendra sur la
stratégie évidemment basile ader jouer à
vous entendre vous avez participé à la
mobilisation
aujourd'hui il ya un mot qu'on a
entendues dans le reportage que vous
avez pas encore prononcé mais qui me
semble essentiel c'est cette idée de
perte de sens pourquoi vous êtes
mobilisés aujourd'hui
parce que cette misère dans laquelle nos
gouvernants mais sa date de de la
deuxième guerre mondiale on a fait un
décrochage à ce moment-là considérable
il faut voir l'étendue dian ce qui était
prix qui était quelques mois à l'époque
qui sont aujourd'hui impossible et qui
font que l'ia il ya une défaillance de
la justice est nécessairement une forme
de justice privée qui va qui va
s'organiser pour pallier cette
défaillance donc ce sont pour les
avocats aussi une vraie préoccupation et
nos camarades de faculté que que nous
avions quoi qu à la faculté et que nous
croisons évidemment souvent nous sommes
vraiment en parfaite concordance sur le
fait qu' on trouve ça absolument indigne
la manière dont ils doivent travailler
partir chez eux avec des dossiers pas
pouvoir avoir du papier et est obligé de
réutiliser leur prêter on se dit mais
comment comment est ce possible donc il
faut des moyens il faut des meilleurs
traitements pour les magistrats ça me
paraît déjà première chose quand on sait
que les magistrats à paris ne peuvent
plus habiter à paris sont obligés de
c'est quelque chose d'impossible de
absolument anormal
et donc nous avocats nous souhaitons
quand on porte le dossier nos clients
que on obtienne une décision judiciaire
on ne veut pas renoncer à saisir le sait
pas c'est pas envisageable florent
vadillo votre point de vue aussi donc je
le rappelle à vous étiez conseillé aux
c'était jean jacques urvoas qui était
ministre de la justice quand vous étiez
son conseiller il ya il ya cinq ans 4 5
ans vous diriez que la situation s est
aggravée depuis
dont la situation ne s'est pas regarder
puisque le gouvernement et les
gouvernements successifs avec nicole
belloubet puis eric dupond moretti ont
effectivement mis de l'argent au profit
du ministère de la justice du budget du
ministère la justice et des
augmentations qui sont effectivement
très importante néanmoins je crois que
françois vers le buffet le disais c'est
une question d'orientation ne sais tu de
cet investissement l'orientation n'a pas
bénéficié à la justice judiciaire et dès
lors s'il ya une vraie occasion manquée
qui que ce gouvernement a créé par ce
que il a mis des moyens budgétaires sur
la table mais il ne les a pas destiné à
justice judiciaire ce qui est un
paradoxe absolu donc la situation du
ministère de la justice s'est améliorée
ces cinq dernières années alors que se
détériorer la situation de la justice
judiciaire alors que les vacances
d'emploi par exemple chez les greffiers
rester à des niveaux trop élevés alors
que les recrutements des magistrats
était inconstant on le voit quand on
regarde années après à l'ailé mais les
réponses de magistrats il ya une forme
d'incohérence dans ses recrutements dont
on ne comprend pas et j'ajoute un point
c'est que l'étude et qui avait été
commandé à l'inspection générale de la
justice pour connaître la véritable
charge de travail des magistrats n'est
toujours pas rendu aujourd'hui donc
c'est à dire qu'on ne veux même pas
savoir combien on recrute de magistrats
pour en faire quoi en quelque sorte donc
je suis vraiment ces cinq années qui ont
été très paradoxal dans le résultat est
dans leur volonté on va voir
effectivement ce chiffre est ici un mot
mais c'est justement pour aborder toutes
ces problématiques que soient organisés
des états généraux de la justice non
justement la question des mois je suis
désolé vous contredire mais la question
des moyens n'étaient pas du tout dans
les états généraux de la justice ils n'y
sont que maintenant à l'occasion
justement de ce mouvement de colère et
de cette manifestation d'aujourd'hui en
réalité ça n'était justement pas un
sujet c'est pourquoi nous allons
dénoncer que ces états généraux de la
justice pour nous n'était pas dans un
bon timing ce matin eric dupond moretti
a soupçonné cette manifestation d'avoir
des arrières pensées électoralistes mais
je pense que les arrière pensées
électoralistes ce ne sont pas les
magistrats qui les ont juste que nous
avons demandé au contraire un timing
différent c'est à dire que nous ayons
une réflexion d'ensemble comment
sérieusement peut-on prétendre en france
réformer et repenser la justice en
quatre mois je vous le demande c'est
impossible ça n'est pas sérieux donc
nous nous avons demandé à ce que ce soit
décroché justement de l'enjeu de
l'élection présidentielle les i c'est
justement la question de la personnalité
du choix de du garde des sceaux par
emmanuel macron elle se pose pourquoi il
le coup il a choisi pourquoi il se prend
elle se pose depuis le début puisque
c'est d'emmanuel macron qui a été le
chercher c'est emmanuel macron qui le
maintient à son poste malgré sa mise en
examen pour prise d'intérêt illégale
d'intérêts il a choisi c'est le chef de
l'état qui a choisi cet avocat là
pourquoi parce que pour toutes les
qualités finalement que les magistrats
lui reproche c'est à dire que pour son
côté grande gueule son ego sa surface
médiatique il était déjà très
très populaire il avait une très grande
notoriété
il est à il était déjà à moitié acteurs
et jouer au théâtre donc il avait comme
ça cette frontière avec le show business
qui intéressait le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron sait pertinemment quand
il va chercher eric dupond moretti ce
qu'il va engendrer comme tempête du côté
du personnel de la justice il le sait
bien sûr donc il va le chercher à
dessein il va le chercher pour envoyer
un message certainement un message à
toute la société mais aussi à la justice
et il ya une phrase d'emmanuel macro il
me semble qui est capitale pour
comprendre le rapport du chef de l'état
à la justice il l'a dit en conseil des
ministres en juillet la justice n'est
pas un pouvoir c'est une autorité et sa
emmanuel macron le répète souvent il me
semble que c'est discutable mais ça
appartient en tout cas c'est à ça à
partir du rex et constitution au chef au
chef de l'état et c'est vrai que quand
on entend vous l'avez dit madame eric
dupond-moretti ce matin sur france inter
dénoncer un peu et peut-être et mettra
soupçon d'instrumentalisation de la
manifestation d'aujourd'hui on peut se
demander si ce n'est pas finalement
emmanuel macron qui parle écoutez on en
discute après
moi j'espère du côté qu'il n'y a pas d'
instrumentalisation mais je ne peux pas
l'exclure n'a échappé à personne que
nous sommes en période pré-électorale et
moi je dis je redis je dirais encore
avec toute la passion qui est la mienne
que les états généraux ont été conçus
pour améliorer la justice de notre pays
et que le boycott a priori le nihilisme
est insupportable on se pose la question
est ce que c'est la position d'eric
dupond-moretti qui je vous le rappelle a
pris une veste monumentale aux
régionales et donc a été complètement
démonétisé dans le gouvernement et aussi
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique un
régional qui avait lieu en juin est-ce
que c'était manuel macron qui parle
derrière eric dupond-moretti haut c'est
uniquement le garde des sceaux et je
voudrais entendre votre réaction vous
l'avais un peu évoquée c'est si le mahb
là après tout donné rôle basile ader
puisque vous êtes plutôt de ceux qui
défendent le bilan du garde des sceaux
instrumentalisation vous répondez à vue
il arrive trop tard ces états généraux
en fait c'est ça la difficulté voyait
déjà eu les chantiers de la justice
enfin il ya eu des tas de choses ça veut
dire qu'ils font encore objective et la
misère de notre justice en france non
mais c'est aujourd'hui pourquoi
aujourd'hui pourquoi la manif est
pourquoi cette date quand vous organisez
une manifestation je pense que vous
réunissez en la mélangeant on va choisir
cette date pour quels objectifs non mais
là là effectivement on peut pas ignorer
qui a vu cette tribune qui a une énorme
moto retentissement qui a justement
dépasser tout calcul quel qu'il soit
enfin comment peut-on imaginer que des
magistrats qui sont des personnes je
pense qu'ils ne sont pas les plus
rebelles qui prêtent un serment d'être
un dîner loyal magistrat à 6000 7000
signe une tribune ça leur fait mal au
coeur ce alors disent qu'ils ne veulent
plus faire ils ne veulent plus une
justice de misère donc ça dépasse bien
les politiques partisanes ce n'est pas
ce qui nous intéresse même nous au
niveau l'union syndicale des magistrats
vous savez très bien nous sommes un
syndicat apolitique et nous le
revendiquons haut et fort il est
absolument pas question de faire du eric
dupond-moretti bashing ça ne nous
intéresse pas nous on ne veut plus de
justice bashing on veut aussi être
respectées être considérée or depuis des
années nous ne sommes pas considérés et
je suis désolé de dire que nous ne
sommes pas plus considéré par eric
dupond-moretti ça par contre c'est exact
basile ader quel bilan vous faites sous
l'action de du mini à la justice si vous
utilisez une image imaginer le titanic
dans les dernières minutes avant de
rencontrer l'iceberg on change de le
commandant de bord pont se disant il va
éviter l'iceberg n'ont évidemment pas sa
faute c'est ce que je disais ça date de
la deuxième guerre mondiale on voit bien
les le décrochage du coup sûr les temps
pris pour pour juger les affaires donc
oui bah lui il chauffe qu'il a d'abord
obtenu ce que ses prédécesseurs n'avait
jamais obtenu son plan du budget que
l'informatisation des tribunaux se
comprend pas qu elle ne l est pas été
fait plus tôt ben heureusement qu'il est
arrivé pour la faire il a quand même
créé je ne sais plus combien je ne suis
pas son avocat avait 750 ou le poste de
magistrat c'est sans doute insuffisant
moi j'ai une proposition pour pour
conjuguer public des affaires s'est il
suffit de regarder ce qui se fait dans
des pays où la justice marche beaucoup
mieux et notamment anglo-saxons ou ou au
canada on prend des anciens avocats pour
juger ils sont ils connaissent bien le
droit et connaissent bien la justice il
faudrait qu'on crée des passerelles dans
beaucoup de vieux avocats qui
demanderaient pas mieux que d'aller
d'aller jugé alors tourner pu être les
mendiantes si j'étais décision que
justice que nous sommes pendant toute
notre vie qui feront de très bons
magistrats et qui évidemment il faut
sans doute ce que je disais tout à
l'heure que les traitements des
magistrats se sont un peu plus
considérables que ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui qui sont franchement indigne
à certains égards mais voilà et là on
irait très vite on purgerait toutou
parce que aujourd'hui il ya un tel flot
à flot mais stoke 2
dossiers à juger parce que les gens
attendent donc ça c'est une mesure
d'urgence pour vous ce qui pourrait être
rapidement et moi je trouve ce serait
une très bonne idée qu'est ce que vous
en pensez d'abord il faut rappeler on
parle à deux ans par la stratégie plus
globale
que chief sur la durée des décisions
puisque nous demanderons vendent à vis
budgétaire à la commission des lois je
rappelle que le délai de traitement en
matière civile est passé de 11 mois et
demi en 2010 9 à 13 8 mois en 2020 et
probablement plus de 13 mois en 2021 en
matière civile et en matière pénale on a
on a également fortement progressé
puisqu'on est par exemple pour les
assises à 41 - en 2021 et des choses ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
encore cc c'est trop mais j'ai pas des
contraires et ouais
je sais bien que c'est trop on essaie de
trouver la solution mais sur cette
solution précise que je suis la
numérisation vous laisse répondre à la
question ok et la question des avocats
j'en suis donc je peux répondre
maintenant mais c'est pas la question la
question
je vais pas faire ça les gens se
marchaient c'est ma réponse
je suis là sur la numérisation est dit
absolument fondamental il est vrai que
le budget a augmenté récemment sur ce
sujet là c'est tardif mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il augmentait la mise en
oeuvre est compliqué mais véritablement
il ya un effort considérable 26 27 % de
ce budget
en revanche sur le nombre de magistrats
les effectifs théoriques sont quasiment
au complet sauf qu'on a donné de plus en
plus de travail à nos magistrats et donc
ils sont absolument débordées dont il ya
urgence à avoir un plan sur plusieurs
années dedans bausch de magistrats c'est
nécessaire alors ensuite il peut y avoir
ponctuellement des mesures d'urgence qui
peuvent être soit avec des magistrats
honoraires qu'ils peuvent revenir soit
avec un certain nombre d'avocats
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont plus en
activité qui peuvent en venir on peut
imaginer cette solution dans l'urgence
mais elle ne peut être de mon point de
vue que temporaire la sujet la réponse
de fond c'est une programmation
pluriannuelle de moyen et long termes
sur une une vision stratégique de la
justice mais de ensuite naturellement
des postes occupés par les magistrats
cécile mamelin jeu rebondit toujours sur
la proposition de
je peux pas être d'accord avec le fait
qu'il équipe qu'il faudrait renoncer à
la justice à la française moi je ne suis
pas du tout pour la justice à l'anglo
saxonne je n'admire absolument pas la
justice anglo saxon ni la justice à
l'américaine par exemple donc je tiens à
la justice à la française et je tiens à
ce que des magistrats puissent exercer
et ce n'est pas nécessairement parce
qu'on a été avocat qu'on ira plus vite
qu'on fera mieux donc moi ce que je suis
un peu d'accord avec monsieur du fait
c'est qu'effectivement il faut un
engagement sur une dizaine d'années une
loi de programmation une nouvelle boîte
programmation avec une augmentation
d'effectifs imaginons à la peu près 40%
nous c'est notre c'est notre demande
officiellement de magistrats de
greffiers parce qu'un magistrat sans
griffes il travaille pas pour rattraper
la moyenne européenne et qu'on ne vienne
pas nous dire aujourd'hui que le chiffre
de cette fameuse ces pêches qui et ses
experts indépendants qui ont bien
comparer les systèmes entre eux qui nous
ont classé dans un groupe c nous sommes
nous sommes les derniers de la classe ou
alors un moment donné nous ce qu'on a
besoin d'entendre en tant que magistrats
et les greffiers c'est d'une espérance
c'est pas forcément de résoudre demain
le problème c'est que ça fait dix ans
qu'on nous dit que ça va être facile on
a une mesure d'urgence qui appelle pas
mal et ça n'empêche pas d'avoir une
stratégie de long terme oui il faut
absolument une stratégie long terme et
reiz résoudre d'urgence ses parents une
justice non j'ai bien entendu lundi la
mère ça me fait penser à l'hôpital de
campagne vous savez au moment des pluies
la pandémie aussi diva il a pu avoir ces
deux médecins il faut créer des hôpitaux
de campagne envoyé les malades dans les
endroits où il y avait plus de places
dans les hôpitaux je pense qu'on est où
cette situation là il ya un tel stock de
gens qui attendent leur jugement qu aux
prud'hommes quinquin salariés attendent
300 villes mais les jugements civile
mais vous avez parfaitement raison se
consacre toujours sur le pénal le pénal
il marche pas forcément très très bien
mais mes maisons mais voilà mai
les lettons en matière civile et
heureusement qu'on a des juges
consulaires qui sont pas des magistrats
professionnels comme dans les autres
pays parce que sinon ce sera encore pire
là bas donc il ya une mesure d'urgence
moi je suggère parce que je ne dis pas
qu'ils seront mieux que les magistrats
je dis simplement que s'il ya des
passerelles de toute façon qu'ils
existent il suffit de mettre
plus des passerelles qu'il faut c'est
maintenant c'est des vagues les
recrutements de personnes extérieures
ayant déjà exercé un métier sont déjà
très nombreux pratiquement la moitié des
promotions en voiture je passe il a
annoncé une année plus importante à
l'image des grands personnages allaient
suis d'accord avec vous sa baisse
augmente on ne comprend pas la logique
des recrutements de nouveaux magistrats
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas poursuivi
une
une ligne ascendante ça n'a pas arrêté
d'accord il suffit qu'ils baissent
qu'est ce que ces
deux
là sont propres alors donc on voit bien
qu'on peut y arriver ouais je ne sais
pas pourquoi l'administration s'est
réservé une justice très chic très
neutre où on allait référé en cinq jours
les les décisions qui sont passés
accessible tout
revient au pouvoir à l'autorité
judiciaire à coup sûr ses expressions
bien sûr c'est dans notre constitution
je suis d'accord avec vous sauf que des
tas d'autres pays européens c'est un
pouvoir judiciaire c'est ce qu'on nous
refuse en france on a peur d'eux on a
peur des jugements sur le gouvernement
des juges y est ça or je ne vois pas le
problème allez quelques chiffres parce
que vous avez cités on a cité cette
augmentation due du budget c'est un peu
le budget de la justice dit 33 ses 33
comme 33 % d'augmentation depuis 2007 et
puis évidemment c'est ce que les
médecins demandent aussi à l'heure à
leurs malades en est à près de 9
milliards d'euros pour 2022 mais alors
si on compare pas aux autres pays
notamment d'autres pays d'europe et
source commission européenne pour
l'efficacité de la justice le budget
moyen par an et par habitant 122 euros
en allemagne
79 euros en espagne 66 euros en france
alors même en europe et nc 64 euros donc
on est un peu au dessus mais on est
quand même très loin de l'allemagne et
de l'espagne vous le voyez je vais
revenir vers florent raidillon 100 euros
suisse mais et 200 euros en suisse en
fou à loisir la flore en vidéo qu'on n'a
pas énormément entendu peut-être pour se
poser la question de je vous pose la
même question monsieur le sénateur de la
responsabilité des équipes précédentes
vous étiez pas ministres influents radio
vous étiez conseiller mais pourquoi
cette grande réforme de la justice à
l'ap a été lancée sous françois lent et
puis vous demanderez vous souffle
nicolas sarkozy parce que évidemment ça
date d'il ya plusieurs décennies
et moi j'ai eu la chance de travailler
pour jean jacques urvoas qui quand il
est arrivé au ministère de la justice
indique la seule loi de justice qui
contestait la loi de finances et qui a
justement obtenu un budget en
augmentation a pu faire descendre de
l'argent dans les juridictions a mis en
place les assistantes justice a commencé
à travailler sur l'environnement de
travail etc donc je vais pas faire le
bilan rassurez-vous de jean jacques
urvoas mais là dessus moi j'estime que
la mort ça avait déjà été fait et de
manière beaucoup plus équilibré que
screen a été le cas budgétairement mais
pour répondre très directement à votre
question pourquoi est ce que les
responsables politiques s'en
désintéressent d'abord parce qu'il ya un
accaparement médiatique et politique
pour les sujets pénitentiaire et pénaux
c'est dire que la réponse et vous le
voyez à chaque fois qu'il ya un problème
il faut construire les places de prison
j'adore lire les programmes des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'ils rivalisent tous du c'est le
concours lépine du nombre de places de
prison qu'il faut construire de 40000
20000 16000 etc personne ne parle du
nombre de magistrats personne ne parle
et non de gré si personne ne parle du
nombre d'officiers de police judiciaire
et de la désaffection de la filière
police judiciaire donc c un sujet
d'accaparement médiatique et politique
deuxièmement vous avez un ministère
lorsque vous êtes à la direction de ce
ministère qui possèdent des directions
de droit des directions opérationnelles
et naturellement les directions
opérationnelles c'est l'administration
pénitentiaire c'est la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse ils mangent
l'esprit du ministre parce qu'au
quotidien ils importent des difficultés
opérationnelles des sujets à régler
troisième explication je donne c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en france le modèle de la
justice à la française c'est le débat
autorités judiciaires pouvoir judiciaire
il y à une indépendance de la justice
donc les parlementaires et l'exécutif
vote des lois mais l'application de la
loi elle est réservée elle est du seul
ressort des magistrats et il ya donc une
forme de
déresponsabilisation du pouvoir
politique qui votent la loi et qui
estime que l'essentiel est fait parce
qu'ensuite il ne peut pas interférer et
c'est heureux dans les brosses et sûr
dans les procédures judiciaires ces
trois éléments la crée un contexte où à
chaque fois qu'on parle justice interne
arbitrages budgétaires on arbitre
toujours au détriment de la justice
judiciaire parce que d'autres postes ont
été jugés plus opérationnels plus
médiatique plus politique est il qu'il
ya une plus grande capacité d'action
c'est tout à fait dommage et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut absolument travailler sur
ce sujet un point que je me tairai sur
la numérisation le gouvernement
d'édouard filet puis de jean castex a
mis un l'argent démesurée sur la
numérisation du ministère de la justice
c'est un échec absolu parce que ce
ministère de la justice ne sait pas
conduire de grands projets informatiques
et donc il y a eu en quelque sorte une
gabegie sur ces sujets là et aujourd'hui
on demande d'appliquer des réformes de
procédure comme si le ministère était
déjà numérisé donc on est en plus sur
une situation ubuesque je crois qu'il
faut qu il y ait une véritable
mobilisation de tout l'appareil d'état
pour aider le ministère de la justice
sur la conduite des grands projets et
pour qu'il y ait une péréquation
budgétaire qui soit enfin à la hauteur
de ce qu'on attend de la justice
française ça veut dire que ça fonctionne
pas en fait non mais il fait risation
mais il faut poser la question
concrètement les magistrats en
juridiction perdre du temps les
greffiers un juridiction perdre du temps
nous avons des applicatifs qu'on appelle
les applicatifs métiers qui sont soit
obsolète soit qui ne marche pas cela qui
tombe en rade excusez moi de
l'expression parce que
on remet notamment cassiopée le fameux
cassiopée tout le monde déteste
cassiopée on vous dira dans les
juridictions
ses logiciels au pénal donc ça ne
fonctionne pas ça tombe en panne à
minuit quand l'audience dure trop
longtemps et bien on ne peut plus
remplir dans cassiopée non nous on
victimes en vue de l'informatique qui
fonctionne qui marche bien évidemment
que nous aussi on veut des conditions
meilleures de travail c'est pour ça
qu'on se bat pour rendre une justice de
qualité pour rsa par respect pour le
justiciable par respect aussi un petit
peu pour les personnels de justice qui
oeuvrent avec des bouts de ficelle au
quotidien effectivement je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
digne un pognon de dagne comme dirait je
ne sais qui a mis dans l'informatique
qui n'a pas donné les résultats
escomptés parce qu'en tout seul alors il
y avait besoin d'une numérisation
assurez vous nous dites a été mal faite
elle a été très mal kate moss a
malheureusement françois noël buffet sur
le lait c'est loupé de la pénitentiaire
ça c'est d'une certaine façon une pierre
dans le jardin des différents pouvoirs
de droite parce que si c'est pas un
marqueur de droite
quand même au peuvent le reconnaître on
peut aborder le sujet de cette manière
là mais la réalité c'est que nos
concitoyens appréhende la problématique
de la justice comme les magistrats comme
les ministres d'ailleurs qu'à travers la
situation pénale et donc on fait la une
du 20 heures sur la personne qui n'a pas
été incarcéré ou s'évader et on
considère que c'est la politique de la
justice derrière généralement cette
mélodie national et compte que c'est une
tendance
est un sujet et ce soir en ténue en est
une occasion pour dire que la justice ce
n'est pas que l' affaire pénale et que
le gros problème il est aussi en matière
civile en matière grise à une facilité
pour les ministres pardon de interrompre
mais pour le ministre se dire je
construis plus de places de prison pour
les candidats à la présidentielle
comprend les envoyer sur cette étape
revient que la matière pénale est un
sujet très important pour nos
concitoyens et en été c'est la question
de l'exécution des peines on peut en
faire un débat il n'y a pas de
difficulté là-dessus matière civile
c'est un on est une très très grande
difficulté alors il était l'émissaire la
justice est probablement celui qui est
le plus en difficulté depuis de
nombreuses années par rapport à d'autres
grands ministères régaliens qui ont eu
la capacité de se remobiliser de se
transformer j'ai pas d'appétence
particulière pour les finances mais
bercy par exemple a réussi à se
transformer totalement et une
administration qui fonctionne
remarquablement bien
et alors que la justice sur la
numérisation vous venez de le dire c'est
une catastrophe on l'a constaté pendant
le coït aucun magistrat n'a vait
importe surtout les greffiers
mais les greffiers sont retrouvés dans
une situation dramatique plein de sujets
cette nature donc la numérisation il ya
besoin d'argent et beaucoup d'argent que
deux mais la question est juste ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est la question
du pilotage de la politique numérique de
la chancellerie qui est par suffisamment
bien organisés et je crois que là-dessus
on doit aller au bout du système mais il
faut l'organiser de façon très
professionnelle c'est un vrai sujet pour
le reste il faut arriver à faire
comprendre que la problématique de la
justice à nos concitoyens c'est une
problématique qui est globale et que
certes on doit construire des prisons
quand on les construit on va le premier
15000 y en as plus 7000 en fait en 1900
la fin du mandat 7000 un peu plus tard
mais on doit s'occuper de la justice du
quotidien et la justice du quotidien
celle ci ville en attend son ordonnance
pour un projet de deux points pour une
séparation parce que on attend une
ordonnance ou une décision en matière de
divorce parce qu'on atteint en donnant
tout ce qu'on apprend un litige avec son
voisin et ça ça ne peut pas continuer de
la manière dont ça fonctionne si on
n'est pas capable peut-être de revoir
certaines organisations de procédure
mais demain tonnes de donner les moyens
aux magistrats de faire leur travail
donc il faut incontestablement plus de
magistrats renforcer l'équipe du juge
c'était absolument nécessaire et de
façon à permettre aux justiciables de
contes et de pouvoir accéder à son juge
c'est une difficulté de fond c'est pas
simplement une déclaration de principe
c'est un vraiment une question
philosophique le justiciable doit-il
garder l'accès à son juge ou passer par
l'ordinateur je pense qu'il doit garder
l'association je reviens sur la tribune
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure quand
on l'a montré au moment voulu évoquer
lors de sa parution c'était 3000
magistrat qui était signataire une
centaine de gauche et donc vous ne
l'avez dit c'est 38 une 3000 signatures
avec cette phrase ne voulons plus d'une
justice qui n'écoute pas et qui
chronomètre tout il faut rappeler aussi
que cet appel il faisait suite au
suicide d'une jeune magistrate charlotte
jeune magistrat de 29 ans une justice
qui chronomètre tout basile ader
concrètement ça veut dire quoi dans
votre travail avoue
quotidien mais que c'est aussi
insupportable pour nous que pour vous
quand on vous dit alors que vous avez
une affaire compliquée oui qui mérite
des explications orales parce qu'il ya
des pièces qu'on ne peut pas comprendre
s'il ya pas d explication que vous avez
dix minutes pour plaider que quelquefois
vous venez avec votre client parce que
c'est la faire de sa vie qu'il a quand
même envie de voir comment ça se passe
et comme ou dix minutes on vous dit tout
et mettre moi ggg 12 à faire au rôle de
cet après midi donc je ne peux pas
consacrer plus de trois quarts d'heure à
votre affaire vous avez vos dix minutes
il faut laisser litres mais ça reste
comme ça quotidiennement c'est plus
qu'un chrono mais c'est une mauvaise
justice je voulais dire tout à la résine
sur la fonction régalienne c'est la
première fonction qu'elle vienne d'un
état si les peuples acceptent essentiel
de laisser les armes pour ne plus faire
la justice privée comme on l'a fait
pendant des millénaires c'est pourquoi
rendre la justice à leur place mais j'ai
un mot churchill que je vous réciter en
41 lorsqu'il est au fond de la guerre
que les états unis sont pas encore
rentrés conte et voir comment va la
grande-bretagne répondait quoi il a
répondu au moins une fois écouté sa
justice va bien donc la grande bretagne
va bien cercle même à ce moment là mais
c'était un mot historique voilà
d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs pardon mais
lisez la splendeur et l'infamie c'est
peut-être dans ce livre que vous avez
trouvé cette citation de churchill qui
raconte la première année de winston
churchill au pouvoir entre mai avril mai
40 et juillet 41 c'est passionnant
pardon oui quand on vous écoute et que
par exemple aux dites vous nous dresser
un tableau vous me dites c'est bloqué en
gros depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
madame vous ne dites on peut pas on on
juge avec un chronomètre extra mais
qu'elles sont un veau moyens d'action
vos levier d'influencé
comment vous arrivez à finalement mais
si vous voulez agir sur le politique
pour que enfin ils trouvent des
solutions de sortie sur moi je veux bien
vous fassiez les tribunes ou manifester
aujourd'hui mais c'est finalement c'est
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau avec moi
d'autres
des années cécile usm a effectivement
appelé à la grève c'est parce que nous
étions un petit peu au bout de des idées
que nous pourrions avoir pour pour avoir
cette influence de vous pensez capable
le fait est que nous n'avons
malheureusement pas beaucoup d'affluence
pourtant nous sommes très craint
manifestement par le pouvoir politique
mais les leviers d'action s'est arrêtée
de rendre une mauvaise justice vite
c'est là qu'on va rendre une justice de
qualité on va inciter nos collègues à
appliquer la loi c'est à dire que la loi
elle n'est pas faite que pour les
justiciables elle est aussi fait pour
les magistrats la durée du temps de
travail elle est aussi fait pour les
magistrats tous les jours les magistrats
condamnent notamment aux prud'hommes
gascon si on participe à l'action des
prud'hommes même si les juges non
professionnels
on condamne des employeurs pour non
respect de la durée du temps de travail
pourquoi est ce que les magistrats
n'auraient pas le droit eux non plus
aussi pardon au respect de leur temps de
travail quand vous voyez que des
substituts procureurs peuvent faire il
ya eu un témoignage qui est parue il a
travaillé où elle a travaillé 24 jours
d'affilée jour et nuit parce qu un
parquetier il est joignable 24 heures
sur 24 heures 24 heures sur 24 les gens
savent que l'hôpital travaille 24 heures
sur 24 mais interrogé les gens dans la
rue ils ne savent pas qu'on travaille 24
heures 5 minutes chacun tiens tiens ce
témoignage je regardais ce ce tweet
c'est une journaliste la journaliste du
quotidien la provence manon variole qui
couvrait aujourd'hui la manifestation
devant le palais de justice de nîmes
elle relate un témoignage sur place nous
devrions être 72 magistrats du parquet
au lieu de treize donc ils sont treize
donc effectivement ça donne ce que vous
écrivez c'est à dire on travaille
pendant trois semaines ou plus d'affilée
et puis ça nous donne aussi volages
écoutez c'était ce matin sur rtl un
reportage au tribunal de ni des
audiences qui parfois se termine à 4
heures du matin j'ai un record à 5
heures du matin
des audiences attire des audiences en
france se poursuivre au delà de 21h
trouvez vous normal qu'en france on juge
devant mais c'est alors vous dites vous
dites que évidemment c'est insupportable
pour les magistrats mais c'est aussi de
la maltraitance pour les sites web mais
bien sûr et avant tout d'ailleurs
comment peut-on accepter d'être jugé à 2
heures du matin lorsqu'on est sur les
bancs assez dur et je veux dire souvent
dans les tribunaux depuis 14h vous
ramène 13h30 c'est insupportable et
c'est pour ça que c'est une souffrance
et là où on vous dit qu'on a honte de
notre justice est un quand même un mot
très très fort dans la bouche de des
magistrats et je crois que ça surtout
était cette tribune et surtout à
l'initiative de jeunes magistrats
pourquoi parce que eux se sont vu
plonger tout de suite donc si vous
voulez c'est un peu le syndrome de la
grenouille terre que nous magistrats
expérimentés j'ai 30 ans d'expérience
nous avons vu l'eau du bain monter
progressivement donc on a petit à petit
supporter on a fait de plus en plus on
dit on va s'en sortir on va voir le bout
du tunnel mais les jeunes magistrats ils
ont dans l'eau bouillante directement et
se disent mais c'est pas possible je ne
vais pas travailler car encore en être
la plus avancée par gc ca et régionales
alors plutôt bien sûr qu'il ya plus de
demandes d'accès au droit mais il ya
aussi des procédés un empilement des
réformes nous n'avons même pas le temps
d'absorber une réforme que déjà les
textes change regardez le code pénal il
est énorme et effectivement on a la
justice cela se fait toujours au
détriment de la justice civile mais
j'aimerais bien qu effectivement
monsieur sénateurs l'a dit que la
justice pénale ne soit pas toujours dans
la bouche de tous les chroniqueurs
judiciaires et tous les hommes
politiques à chaque fois qu'une décision
emblématique où un fait divers qu'est ce
qu'on dit qu'est ce qu'on reproche
justice laxiste justice reparlons effet
vous pensez qu'il ya dans le dos les
médias il ya un discours comme ça en
blâmant il n'y a pas penalty contre met
en valeur certains reportages tout il ya
un gros effort qui est fait par par la
justice par la part d'autres à la part
le journalisme d'investigation qui font
des reportages d'ailleurs l'occasion de
cette manifestation de ce mouvement de
colère a été je pense un mouvement
moment assez unique où nous avons eu des
focus fait sur plein de collègues nous
mêmes nous avons orienté beaucoup de
journalistes de la presse régionale de
la presse nationale qu'ils aient de la
presse spécialisée aussi qu'ils
voulaient des témoignages qui voulaient
des choses concrètes moi quand j'étais
juge aux affaires familiales par exemple
ce chrono mais je l'avais sans arrêt
dans la tête tous les jours je me disais
combien de décisions je réussi à motiver
aujourd'hui est-ce que je vais m'en
sortir et je dormais plus ou moins bien
à la vision pardon vous n'êtes pas payé
à la décision mais bien les vignes bien
évidemment que non ne sommes pas payés
la décision et ce n'est pas ce que nous
demandons nous demandons le respect pour
nous mêmes mais c'est surtout pour le
justicier redonner la parole à florent
radio qu'on a relativement peu entendu
combien de magistrats supplémentaires il
faudrait d'après vous
écoutez c'est compliqué il encore je
pense qu'il faut pas se lancer dans le
concours lépine du du nyong de
magistrats je pense que néanmoins la
politique c'est aussi un peu de
marketing je pense qu'il faut se fixer
comme premier objectif premier objectif
12000 magistrat rapidement parce que
c'est on peut estimer c'est à peu près
le déficit qui lie à pour arriver à
gérer du flux vers 3000 magistrats de
plus parce qu'il faut se méfier aussi
quand on dit le nombre de recrutements
il ya aussi des recrutements qui servent
à combler les départs en retraite donc
ça veut dire que 3000 magistrats de plus
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus de
recrutement puisque toute une génération
de magistrats va partir à la retraite
dans les prochaines années ce sont des
magistrats évidemment ce sont des
greffiers aujourd'hui il ya un taux de
vacance d'emploi des greffiers qui est
de 6% ça veut dire qu'il ya des équipes
qui ne sont pas au complet pour
travailler or le greffier ce n'est pas
un rôle accessoire c'est un rôle qui est
extrêmement encadrées prévues par la loi
et s'il n'y a pas de greffiers il n'y a
pas de décision de justice rendue c'est
la question des assistants de justice
qui est aussi important donc il faut
bien évidemment qu'il faut plus de
magistrats il faut plus de personnel
pour la justice judiciaire en général et
il faut prendre en considération une
chose c'est que l'école nationale de la
magistrature qui est à bordeaux
aujourd'hui est à cinq fois plus que sa
capacité réelle donc si on veut recruter
si on veut adjoindre des personnels
comme mais trader disait parlant des
avocats il faut les former donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut avoir un appareil de
formation qui soit à la hauteur de nos
ambitions aujourd'hui les assistants de
justice les fameux sucres rapides
qu'avec évoqué le ministre ces
assistants de justice ils sont jetés
dans les juridictions sans aucune
formation autre que leurs études leur
bagage universitaire est ce que c'est
normal
est ce qu'on accepterait qu'un policier
par exemple ou un adjoint de sécurité
soient mis sur le terrain sans avoir la
moindre formation ça paraîtrait aberrant
et c'est aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
donc il faut voyez véritablement penser
que derrière cette question du
recrutement il ya toute une mécanique
qui doit se mettre en place et
d'ailleurs c'est une mobilisation
lorsque certains parlent de plan
marshall de la justice il faut prendre
en considération que sa demande donc une
programmation sur au moins 10 ans et un
accord gauche droite qui soient absolus
pour pousser ces sujets là parce que il
y en a assez de divisions qui rende
stérile toute action politique merci
florent va dire merci à tous merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant et éclairant en tout cas on
l'espère pour vous aussi pour nos
téléspectateurs sens